it's time for roses and Rose day with
Ashley round of applause the student I
am good gosh Broadway please come back
you guys we are here with the amazing
Ashley I can thank you I couldn't be
more joyful to watch a season eight
episode three you have come for a treat
yeah I'm so excited I need to do this I
need to brush up on the entire season
you watch this season but you don't
remember it perfectly perfectly of
course but it is probably my favorite
Bachelorette season besides Kaitlyn a
bachelorette I've never met before love
Emily I feel like she sent dudes home
when she was like this is not real for
me yeah I have a daughter I don't have
time for you yes Cheers
yeah this is like the episode where re
is actually in the season you get some
one-on-one don't some guys look good
over here very quickly let me ask you
for your attraction level to Ari
I mean mild but always obviously
good-looking but you don't know just how
sexy they are or how much they can like
really grab a girl's attention until
they're in person and I think Ari has
that swag where he'll make you nervous
please name names oh I think Nick is
like that like Nick is obviously hot but
like a lot more alluring in real life
interested I think and so if we went out
together we'd be good maybe good wingman
cuz we would not have the same taste in
guys okay Peter okay Peter is very tall
in person and he dresses very well yeah
so that I'm like but he also photograph
everything's perfect well never I'm not
when fear is not in that you know no he
just he's as good all around just hot in
person on TV what she does is she has
the guys meet her friends and her
friends kind of quiz them so
neaten or gals this feels that gives us
yesterday it was actually over five
years ago dreary when you're like I said
I was in college I was actually in grad
school yes yes cheers to your master's
degree we don't have them you're welcome
Sean Lowe goes to talk to the friends
and they ask him this blonde who will
take your shirt off first and then he
does takes it off how do you feel about
a guy with no hair on his body oh my
gosh that was a topic my podcasts with
Ben this week Ben Higgins has chest hair
and he likes it when a girl appreciates
it and I agree I don't want to be holy
thing I agree I mean I'm not gonna judge
like if you can't grow hair Yeah right
hey naturally barren that's totally fine
but I don't need somebody who's like
waxing and like I cry like a little
manliness little scruff you know I like
scruff on the face do you - I think
every guy looks better with like a
three-day scruff yeah we are like so on
the same page always wait I said high
status she says what if I gain weight is
that okay and he said no it's not why in
all the shows that you've been on what
is the moment and even the ones you've
watched where you were like that person
said too much too soon
probably myself cheers to the honesty
and the self-awareness well you told me
last time I talked to your baby
selective
I like that expression I want to say
that from now on I'm selective are you
dating anyone now yeah cuz you haven't
you haven't found one you want to select
I'm at that place in my life where I
want to find what my family has what my
parents have he talked so much about his
own family he oh he's so shiny there
anyone telling you if you look like on
camera definitely they have people with
tissue the producers have tissues and
they're like oh blah look at that now I
like the way re handled this
rollercoaster moment oh my god is she
saying she's scared first he's a scared
like that that's the best reason to go
to a museum part with a guy to get him
to live yeah see how he handles that
that's what I like to do yeah throw up
on someone and see how they react I
threw up on I threw up next - Jared once
and went very poorly who's that on
camera I was months later and it went
poorly Lane it was the end of the end
[Music]
cheers to the end of the end to be
honest it was really the actual
definition of the beginning of the end
part - I want to get into their dinner
day because this is where I started to
like Ari because he is so real so we're
gonna watch the dinner date very closely
he's such a great guy and I had so much
fun I could be myself but I also want to
make sure that we're compatible as far
as life and fun so she wants to make
sure they're compatible but I feel he
wants to make sure - okay cheers to an
amazing day that's a really good hair
like he's thick hair girl I think it was
like super close to them the little girl
at the time was 4 and the boy was 6 and
I would do this Google last girlfriend
he was very close
okay she had two kids he dated some that
she they live together children came up
like I was ready to take that step
forget about them and not eating any
food I never do you eat beforehand
mm-hmm or if you're me you do the other
day because I know this is V s great to
be s it's not that like I'm hungry I
just like I don't have food sitting in
front of me without eating it having
children came up like I was ready to
take that step you know I was ready and
she was like I never want to have
children you know I think this is good
and then it was like oh you remind me
too much of my ex-husband because of
racing he's not trying to hide what he
thinks may be a turn-off right
so bottom line she gives him the rose
but this date made me like Ari and I
want to cheers to Ari right now in this
moment you're sorry yeah mm-hmm this was
he's soaked and ready now I know that
the only reason I like high ground there
was because what's her growing I don't
know I just came up with that we're like
hmm is that like his dating track record
in the past five years has been anything
like flingy or like very young and with
you and if he was wanting that right now
would he want to be with somebody very
young did he get caught up in like the
play earnest that is being a bachelor
cast off how prevalent is that how
easily but how much do you see the
illness that you just brought up which
is getting caught up in being a bachelor
nation play yeah it's 50/50 that's call
you did the highbrow that's the high
road Cheers Taniya hmm oh I hit a high
note every time I drink do you want try
with me
okay so you'd kind of do it as you're
finishing your drink
[Music]
so then they go on a carousel and I
cannot wait to show you this because re
do you know his nickname ya the kissing
bandit yeah
you sent you're saying that skeptically
no no no I believe it I know this as
team Jeff Jes Jeff Jeff Jeff as I was
holy moly did our know how to kiss you
could just visually see it yeah
okay so they go on a carousel together
and the first kiss look at how he grabs
I mean it small not a tease I know it
says oh it's the best and his hands are
so big and he's so lippy and slow and I
liked it earlier you did not remember
some of the contestants on the show but
you remembered the deep oh yeah okay you
just get Tommy the article like he does
the hand thing which every girl loves
them and they grab the face yes our crew
guys are learning it goes really slowly
it would slow I think he's even
smoldering like the eye is he like kind
of teases her he's like more about mouth
not much time too much time to me the
cardinal thank you sure you people like
a little bit a little little bit but
here's the thing my younger self would
not tell someone you're a terrible
kisser myself now my 29 year old so
maybe like it's too much tongue man okay
chill the [ __ ] out because I don't have
time for this and I'll communicate to
that would you say that I probably would
do it now but my 28 two year-old self
did not drink so much more than you this
keeps happening since they have guests
it's a problem don't worry ever as they
under the table Emily and Ari after her
kind of trauma with Kalyn the other dude
who she sent home have this really
adorable private moment they were dying
to do my god
run away drinking their margaritas
having a moment off to the side you just
touch decision these are the moments you
live for as a contestant if she's having
a confessional moment with you it's a
good thing cuz it's real wait what do
you mean like she's confiding in him oh
I thought you'd be really confessional I
don't know it's like sort of like that
like they're whisked away to like a
little secret area and nobody else is
watching but it's not really their
one-on-one time because they're standing
I love this little moment they have
options yeah I really only was their
actual owner one time I think this is
like a little extra time that's the
thing and it feels intimate and real
yeah and she just said he was here for
her how hard is that mouse to strike up
like talking about other people and you
know listening to the lead talk about
other people but still not being a
photographer you know I think you have
to keep it to a minimum I think in some
twisted way it's sort of a good way to
bond with the lead but I think you
actually it has to be like 10% in your
normal life you would talk about your
friends right so like these are kind of
your friends in the current oh that is
such a revelation for me these are your
common friends my mind is literally but
I just realized that because it no
because I mean as much as I've talked to
everyone in there I kind of never made
that connection yeah because you don't
really have much else to talk about
social you don't even know what's going
on in the world you haven't seen the
news no it's not like what do you think
of the recent news I can say that no I
mean you never see people discussing
current affairs ah yeah now just the
affairs they're currently yeah let's do
what we call a shameless plug which is
where you talk about like the most
important thing in your life which I
feel is currently your podcast both
podcasts I have the Ben and Ashley
almost famous podcast but I Heart Radio
and then I have my other podcast which
is the I don't get it podcast with my
sister and my best friend and on the
almost famous podcast
it is usually based on Bachelor current
events but we also talk about
relationships and love and
that and I give our best advice even
though I don't know how much of an
advice giver I should be on that topic
you've been through the wringer I have
them through the wringer again just to
get that hasn't worked out doesn't mean
I haven't experienced the feelings be
selective if you selective you guys
follow her on social media
thank you so much for watching episode 3
with us thank you for being here let's
do one more Cheers
and we'll just have one more little
drink all the time you guys thank you so
much for being here make sure to follow
Ashley on social media and listen to her
amazing podcasts subscribe to VT on
YouTube a like us on Facebook we're here
every Tuesday with roses and Rosie and
now we just have to say bye bye